luke here at the outdoor boys youtube
channel and today this family of five
is going to test our medal with our
72-hour kits yes
we are going to go out in the woods and
survive with nothing but
what i have here in my family of five
72-hour kit wait i thought we were just
going camping
no this is gonna be us versus death
survival of the fittest we're gonna see
whether our kits
can keep us alive uh i i don't i don't
want to do that
well becca what are you gonna do when
zombies attack the house
or we have some sort of communist
uprising
i gotta take that well fine
we're gonna go out in the woods and
we're gonna test both of our 72-hour
kits
and we're gonna see whose is better
you guys ready to go survive yeah
i brought a fan i'm going to kill a deal
too
all right guys we got a place where we
can pull over and not interfere with
traffic
we got a spring coming out of the rocks
where we got some fresh water
does it taste good
oh we even got a little spot where i can
camp down there what do you think babe
is this a perfect spot
let's do it what do you think about this
oh oh that water's perfect
so i think i think we found a decent
spot for your 72 hour kit
i think we did it
yeah this is why you buy a 16 foot
trailer right here folks well apparently
becca's
72-hour kit includes sunscreen and swim
trunks for the boys
so they're getting changed to go swim in
the river and while they do that
i'm going to get my real 72-hour kit
ready to go
these two bags are my 72-hour kit
everything we need for the entire family
that's a family of five
this bag contains all of our sleeping
and shelter needs a tent
sleeping bags and mats for everyone and
over here is everything else
so let me take this out get set up and
i'm going to show you what i put in my
72 hour kit what's the matter buddy
now do you want to use mommy's 72-hour
kit or do you want to use daddy's
72-hour kit my mine's cool too
both of the bags i'm using for my
72-hour kits are waterproof dry bags
because the stuff i have in here it's
useless if it gets
wet all right let me show you what's in
the top of my bag first i've got this
dry box here
with a couple of rechargeable headlamps
i have an emergency response radio
that's both solar powered
and crank powered i also have
this satellite phone it works with the
iridium satellite network
it allows me to call and send text
messages anywhere in the globe as long
as i can see the sky
this is a battery bank that has
solar panels as well i can charge
my phone wirelessly this way and it's
got little ports
for plugs so i can charge all my other
electronics the next thing in my bag is
my first aid kit because when you need
it you need it fast
this one's from a company called
surviveware it's a virginia company a
little mom-and-pop operation this
has a lot of things in it and i've
supplemented
it with a few things of my own as well
all right so this is all the things that
come with the kit you got biodegradable
wet wipes
knife multi-tool signaling mirror
uh scissors a little saw some other
little odds and ends but the nice part
is
that everything is labeled and you got a
little bit of survival stuff and a lot
of first
aid stuff but i added a few things to my
kit i added some large gauze and
surgical dressings for bigger
scrapes and wounds i also got burn
dressing it's something you put on a
burn immediately after it happens so it
helps
relieve pain and also reduces scarring
here's a set of gauze with a chemical
called quick clot it helps stop bleeding
so if someone's got a real gusher
you go and use this in addition to other
first aid techniques
to try to stop the bleeding quickly and
then i've got some comfort first aid
items i got some dayquil and nyquil
i've got some throat lozenges some
neosporin
some poison ivy wipes bactain pain
relief and itch relief
some mimodium ad and this all fits
inside
the first aid pouch if anyone in your
family has special medical needs
make sure those medications make it into
the 72-hour kits
this right here is my cooking equipment
big thing of isobutane
a little backpacking stove and i've got
a three cup tea kettle
next in the bag is our toiletries and
right at the top
is dust mask we got toothbrushes and
toothpaste
diaper wipes feminine hygiene products
trash bags
tissue paper a note pad and some pencils
hand towels razors wet wipes and some
shampoo conditioner
eating utensils and some fire starting
stuff
we have diapers pull-ups and toilet
paper and i've got four of these life
straws
they're filters that you just drink
through this packet contains something
called chlorophyll
which is a chemical that both cleans
water and makes it taste better
next i've got adhesive body warmers
these things last 12 hours i have five
rain ponchos
and i have five emergency survival
bivvies i've got this book
it's on field medicine or survival
medicine
well everyone but me is in their
swimsuits so i think i need to stop
talking and go get changed because that
river
needs to get swamming my wife's 72-hour
kit may or may not have included
sunscreen in my swim trunks
[Applause]
there you go a nice soaking rock yeah
this is good
i'm doing it
it's a baby tone that is the tiniest
little toad
look at him all right let's go upstream
and explore a little bit
white water rafted without the raft
the boys are having a ball they just go
upstream plop down in a swift current
and let it drift down and just
rinse and repeat enjoy this becca
this is pretty perfect actually you want
to ride on daddy's shoulders
okay
that's cool oh there's my other son he's
drifting away
this is so much fun but i better get
some dinner ready so that the troops can
eat as soon as the sun gets down
the remainder of my bag is just
food to feed my family of five for three
days that's
45 meals but just that alone
it's 20 pounds here let me kind of show
you
three different types of meals that i
have in this bag
the first type of meals i have are these
mountain house dehydrated backpacking
meals
they're very light they're not that
expensive and they only take about one
or two cups of boiled water
to cook if you have to carry all your
food on your back hands down this is the
best way to go
however i find that if you eat nothing
but these for three days straight you
get super constipated
which saves on toilet paper the next
type of meal i have
are these mres or meals ready these are
based off what they give the soldiers in
the field they're more diverse and they
have more calories
than the backpacking meals the biggest
problem is
that they're heavy they're also
expensive
and some of the companies that sell them
are a little bit
fast and loose with how they package
these the real cool part about mres is
you don't need to bring
any cooking utensils there's a little
pouch in here
and you add water to it and it causes a
chemical reaction that heats up your
meal so you can have a hot meal
with nothing more than this pouch and i
think tonight
i am going to try out these mres and if
you like any of this stuff
i'm going to put links in the
description to where i got this i
actually bought this
from a local company here in virginia
the final type of meal i have in my bag
are these emergency rations they're just
like little power bars
and this right here is 3 600 calories
they're actually
really tasty i like these better than
clif bars
or any of the energy bars they have on
the markets and the kids will eat them
a lot more than they do those other
products as well they're super compact
and they last forever so it's no big
thing to throw a couple bricks of these
in your bag all right now that i've
shown you what's in my kit i'm gonna
pull out some of these mres and we're
gonna see if the heaters work and we're
gonna taste them and
see what we think also becca's got the
kids in the trailer
and here in a few minutes she's gonna
show us what food she brought
hey guys how does beef ravioli and
chicken breast
in barbecue sauce sound good uh-oh it
looks like it might be raining so
becca's busting out her
uh 72-hour kit awning it started
thundering over there we might get some
rain so i'm gonna get my shelter up
in a hurry five sleeping bags and mats
and a tent is
massively bulky but it's not that heavy
so i decided to make it into a separate
bag that way depending on the emergency
i can choose to grab this or not grab it
i've got a three-man
dome tent in my kit it's a really tight
fit with our
family of five but my kids are still
little so we can get away with it
oh here it comes
it's rain poncho time
it looks like this is getting serious i
bet you really regret bringing the rv
now
don't you
all right i gotta get this poncho off it
is so flipping hot
oh oh i smell like dirty dog
got a little problem the stakes to the
tent weren't in the bag
and so i didn't stake down the tarp and
so the tarps letting a lot of rain
into the tent
i got the tarp stake down but it really
wasn't made for this it's like wearing a
mini skirt in the wintertime
just doesn't cover enough well this
poncho is completely unbreathable and
stifling hot
but gosh darn it it's keeping me bone
dry so
i like the poncho i've got water leaking
through the walls of the tent
and pooling down here on my pad i'm
using my poncho
to try to keep my pad dry there's a good
amount of water
cooling on the bottom of this tent
already this is where having waterproof
bags really comes in handy
i can put it up against the wall of the
tent and still keep my stuff dry
this little rainstorm is really exposing
the flaws of my tent
i might be able to fit my whole family
in here in good weather
but when it's bad like this we need to
cook inside we need to store our gear
inside
you can't touch the walls and so this
becomes a much smaller space i need
a better tent and i need a bigger tent
if i'm gonna actually
use this in survival situations well
beck and the kids really wanted to try
out the mres and check them out so uh
i better put on my poncho and head on
over there
don't tell becca but i think the awning
is absolutely brilliant
oh thank goodness for that oh hey babe
every time i take that poncho off it
smells like dead dog
you having fun
all right guys let me give you a tour of
becca's 72-hour kit
you can see it's got a kitchen a little
bathroom shower
which where we keep all the wet clothes
got a little closet right there
and it's got a set of bunk beds and we
got the top bunk folded up right now so
i could sit down and use that as a seat
got a queen bed and we have another bunk
bed up here that pulls down the boys
sleep in
this also turns into a kitchen table and
it got a little tv
which we never use and it's got a little
fridge do you like a cold hawaiian sun
from my
72 hour kids yeah yeah
was that strawberry lilikoi flavored
hawaiian sun oh
you're a beautiful woman you know you
want it
all right we're going to bust open one
of these mres
here cheddar potato with artificial
bacon bits
spread soup mix and this is the
cardboard sleeve
tear this open fill it up to this line
tuck our entree in there
now we got a little bit of smoke coming
out and the heater's pressed up against
the entree that should warm that up
just let that sit for a few minutes you
guys want to try the applesauce this is
soldier applesauce
it tastes like old applesauce mixed with
mac and cheese
these don't taste old they're in my 72
hour kid
we're going to try the coconut peanut
butter spread
i actually like that that coconut pita
brush spreads good
try that like that it's good
it is it is good yeah the coconut peanut
butter is good
let's see meals pretty hot but not so
hot that it burns my hands and then uh
voila beef ravioli
that actually looks pretty good
that's okay it's about on par with
canned ravioli which is also in my 72
our kitchen
all right let's crack this one open oh
hello well this
must be the beef brisket
that's actually pretty good the the mres
are not dehydrated which is what makes
them heavier
but man they taste a lot better than the
dehydrated meals
that was uh that's actually pretty good
oh my goodness there's pop-tarts in here
there's a piece of pop-tart we like that
santa fe style rice and beans
there's here the santa fe beans and rice
silver what do you got there this is my
mess of a 72-hour kit i was in a hurry
so i just threw it in a box and i have
plenty of room so it worked
um i'm my obligatory first aid kit um
i added some kid's medicine some adult
medicine
um some ear plugs hand sanitizer
muffin mix makes good pancakes just add
water and then you don't need to bring
syrup
oh yes chef boyardee good hot or cold
granola bars fruit snacks
nathan's favorite cup of noodles cup of
noodles
spaghetti and meatballs shelf stable
milk
this milk doesn't have to be
refrigerated oh look at you
this is even easier than an mre mac and
cheese for nathan
check it out is something i made just
two bent pieces of steel from
lowe's a piece of wood and uh keeps the
boys from rolling out of bed
it just goes underneath the mattress
like so you like that
yeah just put the rails in upside down
and then when you fold up the beds
they stay out of the way all right we
got jacob down here we got mommy over
here
tom and nate chilling up top we gotta
get these boys to bed
mom brought a bunch of battery-powered
fans
and uh the boys are digging that because
it's hot in here you like the fan
well the kids are to bed and we're gonna
sit out here and watch fireflies
and then maybe a movie on my phone that
doesn't count as cheating because
i brought the phone and the solar
charger rebecca brought the camping
chairs
and we're here just a few feet away at
the riverside and we're checking out
these tide pools for all the little
creatures at night and it's really fun
oh it's over here
there we go look at that
nice little crawfish it's a fish see him
right there
little creek chub
you see him got him oh
he's multi i can feel it okay
is that cool becca that's so cool all
right
let's go watch a movie well it's getting
pretty late and we've had a good time
but beck and the kids are asleep in the
rv and i guess uh
i guess i'm gonna go to sleep by myself
over here in the tent
oh this tent is so waterlogged
more water up there better not fall off
my mat
i guess i'll uh i'll see you guys in the
morning
well i was alone in my wet soggy tent
last night and it started raining
buckets again and i realized that
everything i love
was in this 72-hour kit so i decided to
come over here and join the party
no regrets you guys sleep well
[Music]
oh you got your blankie so you really
think ours is better i'll admit that
there are some benefits to you
to your 72 hour candidate and it doesn't
have half an
inch of water in the bottom of it it it
rained pretty hard all
night long i kept waking up and shining
the spotlight off the window to make
sure the river hadn't rose and taken out
my tent
but uh we're good
yeah this half of the pillow is soaking
the mat is soaking over there that's a
good puddle of water there
yeah i made the right call last night i
just should have made it sooner we
definitely need
to get a better tent for our 72 hour kit
i am very glad
everything was in waterproof bags oh my
goodness
you want me to make breakfast love you
buddy
time to make my princess some breakfast
in bed
this one is hash brown potatoes with
bacon peppers and onions
when i bought these mres i bought like
twice as many as we need for our 72 hour
kit
i figured they'd be good for camping and
plus you always want to test them out
before you throw them in your 72 hour
kit there's the obligatory cracker
grape jelly table syrup
pork sausage patty there's a cinnabon in
here
it's a cinnabon pop-tart looking thing
mom gets first bite because she gave
birth to you you gave them life becca
you don't have to share
let's sit on the stoop let's see if the
hash brown and sausage is done
no that's feeling nice and toasty really
is
heat it up to a nice temperature
i don't know why this one came with a
spoon it's okay
yeah two sets of crackers and two things
of grape jelly you guys go and share
that
me and becca really like the hash browns
and sausage but the kids don't
they they did not approve if you have a
lot of kids there's always
one of them that doesn't like what you
cooked for them so having a variety of
foods can sometimes make things a little
bit easier so
i kind of like having the mres and some
real food a little bit of this a little
bit of that
it helps i really had a good time
testing out these 72 hour kits and it
opened my eyes
to ways we can improve them i definitely
need to get a better tent
and i definitely think becca was right
in bringing spare clothes i mean i
i didn't pack any spare clothes and
that's just completely unrealistic
our two 72-hour kits exposed a
fundamental difference in how we
approached this
becca was more about everyday comforts
and i was more about extreme survival
and
i think both approaches have a lot of
value
guys did you have fun yeah yeah
well hopefully you guys had fun too if
you want to see more videos from the
outdoor boys youtube channel don't
forget to
click subscribe if you like this video
don't forget to check out the outdoor
boys youtube channel where we have
hundreds of videos just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
saturday morning
and hit that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching
my 72-hour kit has pastries